[Music]
you
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000s it's always I'm your
driver on this journey today I wanted to
look at a few of my games that I've
played recently well pretty recently and
the theme of the games is gonna be what
to do in the early middle game right out
of the opening sometimes this is an easy
question to answer if you're super
familiar with the opening and you have
all your prep done before hints and you
know the plans and the ideas but
sometimes you do have to figure it out
over the board so these are three games
where I tried to figure it out over the
board with varying success so I wanted
to look at what I did well what I did
wrong and what my opponents did and will
try to come to some conclusions about
ways you can kind of apply this to any
game things you should be thinking about
ways you should approach each new
position so this first game is a game I
recently played at the Chicago Open I
went over a lot of my Chicago open games
a couple weeks ago I think but this one
was not shown and I did manage to win
this game so let's take a look at what
happened in the opening it was a Kings
Indian defense and these were all
opening moves that both me and my
opponent knew and he played 97 which is
one of the most popular lines but I'm
wildly unprepared so I had no idea what
I should do against 97 I started with
castling cuz we were still in the
opening and you know castling is almost
never wrong you played a 5 and then I
had this feeling that I knew Bishop III
was the main move against ePHI for a
main move and so I decided I would play
Bishop III and figure it out from there
so he took no he didn't take he played a
queen II 7 and this was kind of the
first point in the game where okay I'm
definitely out of opening out of the
opening all my pieces are develops how
do I start to develop a plan how do I
make moves that make sense here and so I
wanted to ask you guys
what would you do with white here what
would you be thinking about it
sure so yeah I mean this is the base of
blacks pawn chain but it's a little it's
a little tough to get at right you know
if your so yeah rook c1 would be a
sensible move but what I was worried
about in the game is I think black might
have made a threat right he's gonna take
here so yeah one big option is d5 and
then what's the other main option yeah
so you can play d5 or you can take yeah
this is this is a fairly common
structure that you get out of the King's
Indian and so here I had to decide what
made more sense to me so I'm unfamiliar
with the opening and my opponent has
been playing instantly so far so I'm
pretty sure he's still in his book and I
had to decide if I was more comfortable
playing d5 here or D takes e5 so let's
just try to think a few moves ahead
I play d5 what is probably black going
to do yeah you could play something like
c6 I don't know so much about c5 I was
kind of expecting at some point this
night to come into c5 at some point
maybe after kicking this Bishop away it
was something like Knight g4 and there
would be a lot of pressure on my center
and that's not to say that deep I would
be wrong but I decided I was a lot more
comfortable playing D takes e especially
after black committed to Queen e7
because this is not really the the ideal
square for the Queen cuz after D take C
D take C and now I have this move Knight
d5 and so now this Queen is gonna have
to kind of run away and defend this
weakness that you pointed out on c7 so
okay he plays Queen d8 I have to solve
this problem of the e pawn and I can do
that a few different ways honestly
they're all fine I think yeah Jonathan
sure so uh yes so you can take this
night but then you know I hadn't
actually decided in the game how I
wanted to recapture but I was pretty
heavily leaning towards see takes and
this gives me access to that weakness on
the c7 flex gonna get some counter play
definitely on the e pawn here but I
thought that that would be you know I
mean I thought I could be able to I
would be able to handle something like
that so yeah 95 Queen d8 and now I do
have to solve this problem of the e pawn
right and in the game I didn't think it
mattered very much how I could do it I
could play Queen c2 I could play Knight
d2 or I could play even Knight back to
c3 if I wanted and offer a draw but I
probably wanted to win I was a bit
higher rated than my opponent so it
turns out later on I found out Queen c2
is the main move but in the end it
doesn't matter all that much so I played
92 in the game to defend also you know
giving my F pawn some access to defend
my my pawn here in the game he played c6
I just played a sensible move I didn't
want to trade pieces or too many pieces
cuz I felt like I had more space so I
instead of taking on f6 which is fine I
just played Knight c3 which is also fine
and my opponent played Queen to e7 and
so for the past three or four moves I've
kind of avoided actually making a plan
I've just been kind of gaining some
Tempe because my opponent's pieces were
awkwardly misplaced but this is kind of
the first point in the game where you
really have to sit down or I really had
to sit down and come up with something
to do the last few moves haven't really
made a great deal of progress for my
position and my opponent really hasn't
made a great deal of progress either but
okay let's figure out what should White
be doing in this position
so how do you go about that how do you
make your pieces better or how do you
get rid of this I don't think you
actually want to get rid of this right
because what happens if this pawn like
say you played at four at some point you
captured then all of a sudden this
Bishop looks very very strong
so what what can we do really important
to also think what black is going to try
to do if you can't find your plan which
in this case it's a little bit hard to
find the right plan for white sometimes
it is easiest to look at your opponent's
plan and see how you can play against
that so what is black going to do here
Queeny seven kind of Telegraph's it sure
so there's an open D file so black might
be planning to come to d8 and kind of
put pressure down this line but there's
an even more pressing plan that I think
black is going to do yeah Jonathan yeah
he wants to get this Knight to d4 right
so I was looking and I was like okay
well the path that makes the most sense
is Knight c5 to e6 to d4 and then I'm
probably gonna be in some trouble if I
let him play all these moves for free
and then he has a knight on d4 cuz the
counterpart d5 is defended by the c6
pawn and so that plants not too hard to
come up with we're right we know what
black wants to do and even if we can't
figure out what white wants to do we can
figure out how to stop black and so this
is a very nice way to come up with a
plan in positions where it's not so
clear exactly how you should be playing
it's almost always fine to play against
your opponent's plan if you can't find
one for yourself so how did we how can
we play against this plan of knights e5
to e6 to d4 when you start asking this
question instead of what am i doing
comes a little bit easier to find moves
yeah sure Sun ip3 would be would be one
way to go about it let's think what can
a black do here yeah I mean you know
black might just play Rick d8 now sure
Queen c2 and now I might start coming
this way I think this would actually be
an OK way to play though I don't think
Nyepi 3 is a bad move but I came up with
what I think is a slightly better move
than Knight B 3 because in the long run
I did kind of think I might want to
expand on this Queen side right it's
kind of where my bishops are pointing oh
well I guess they're pointing in both
directions but it's kind of where my
Knights are aimed as well and it's kind
of where I have more space so I thought
maybe a someday I want to expand over
here so I was a little reluctant to play
this Knight b3 move
so yeah I mean in the long run you'd
like to play b4 obviously you can't
right now so I came up with kind of a
tactical way to stop night c5 so yeah
night a4 is also playable it's
interesting but again I'm not so sure
this is this is the right way to go
about things it's a little awkward
again black might just play something
like Earth d8 so okay
so if we don't play an IP three and we
don't play Knight a four how else can we
stop Knight c5 Julian is here but I
think Julian has already seen this game
not quite so no move I played was Queen
a4 and I think this is a this is a
pretty nice way to stop my c5 right see
a 95 you have this kind of a little
strange pin where you know you usually
don't see a queen pinning a piece to
another Queen but that's just the case
here and this would be a pretty awkward
for black to deal with so quit i-4 is
stopping 95 and it's also preparing b4
so this is why I decided on this move no
I think black should probably just
continue with something like maybe York
d8 I don't think I'm threatening to take
a7 really so just Rick d8 and go back to
his regional plan without kind of
panicking in the game he was a little
bit nervous about before I think and he
played a 5 to try to stop it so once
again
how should I continue now I've kind of
found my plan right and the way I found
it was thinking what can my opponent do
and I came up with Knight c5 and then I
found a way I could stop it right so I
want to continue shutting down my
opponent's counter play and maybe try to
find a way to improve my pieces
so what can we do
people of YouTube chat have suggested it
in slightly different lines but yeah
there it is now so see five and the idea
is we're taking control of some weak
squares you know we may not have a d5
outpost but maybe someday we'll have the
d6 outpost right so in there the the
same tactics where if Knight c5 there's
simply queen a3 right and unfortunately
for my opponent he fell right into this
trap and took on c5 once again it
probably would have made a lot more
sense to just play something like rook
d8 and I don't know maybe Knight c4 here
and Knight f8 is as possible and I
really think white is doing quite well
here so maybe you can't even play now to
fate but I don't I thought this would be
a pretty comfortable game for white and
there's not really more you can ask for
out of an opening where you weren't
really entirely sure what you're doing
so the trick here to learn is when
you're not sure what to do a great way
to find moves is to look at what your
opponent's trying to do and then look at
ways to stop it and so that's how I came
up with Queen a4 which i think is
actually just just the best move with
that in mind we can take a look at how
it ended so I played Queen a3 pitting
the knight to the Queen b6 defending I
played Knight b3 I think I could have
played Knight a 4 and this was a bit
stronger because of Knight takes b6
threats there was something that I was
worried about in the game but it was all
nonsense
so just Knight b3 instead 97 9 a 4 and
there's simply too much pressure on this
night I took on b6 and after this simply
brought a rook to the open file and so
I'd say we're beyond kind of the early
middle game at this point
it's pretty easy to play now you just
bring your pieces into the game I took
Queen c7 Bishop d6 and after Queen a7
there's a nice tactic to kind
in the game here I'll let you guys try
to find it
how to win
close you can do a bit better than that
I don't know what what would what black
play here maybe just develop a piece or
something Bishop e5 might be winning
right yeah think more unnatural and more
forcing the YouTube chats ahead of you
attack important pieces you guys got it
yes cuz everybody got it this should be
eight hits the Queen and threatens
checkmate and on Bishop f8 there's her
d8 just pinning so my opponent should
have resigned here instead we played on
and on and on and on and on and on and
on and then I won so yeah the big
takeaway from that game aside from you
know fun tactics is when you can't
figure out what to do look at your
opponent's plan see if you can prevent
that and quite often that leads you into
the natural plan that you should be
following yourself there was one
question about I saw in the YouTube chat
ya stiff Knight c4 works here and Knight
c4 works just as well as Knight a 4 and
they're both probably better than I be 3
think but yet everything's the same with
just attacking b6 any other questions
about this game the idea kind of makes
sense you know look to your opponents
plan to find your own all right so
that's the only game I won that I'm
going over today let's take another look
at a game I had against Nikolas Theodore
ooh I think I've played him twice now in
my life and I've lost both games
horribly that guy's pretty good at chess
but let's take a look what happened here
well he's really 2570 now I know he was
over 2500 when we played but I don't
think he was quite that high one of the
no we were at pan amps so it was a team
competition yes
so anyways night a six we have another
Kings Indian defense and another line
that I am not booked up on and once
again I figured
Kathlyn can't be bad he played e5 I
played a rookie one here which is
probably okay
he played Bishop g4 I played Bishop III
because I heard of this idea where if
the bishop goes to g4 then the knight
can't go there and the big problem
Bishop III and a lot of positions is
Nigel
simply attacking it takes and I take
with the night he takes my bishop
I play Knight takes Bishop which is
pretty weird and pretty dumb and pretty
bad but that's okay probably it would
have just made a lot more sense to take
this with any other piece like the queen
or the rook or the queen or the rook
probably not the other night no it can't
hang this pawn but okay it's fine I
played Knight takes Knight G for hitting
my bishop and so the point of Knight
takes was I was thinking after Knight g4
I will play Bishop d4 and challenges
bishop and everything will be great
Oh basically yeah
trading the right pieces though right I
mean this Bishop is this Bishop is
blacks best piece so I wanted to try to
trade it off but uh Bishop d4 actually
is quite bad here I'm trying to remember
why I had this figured out oh it's
probably just because of takes so takes
takes and then uh see if you guys can
find the tactic here
okay so Queen h4 but then the point is
yeah you just play c5 and my queen has
nowhere to go nowhere to go to defend f2
thankfully in the game I realized this
so I play Bishop f4 but now you know of
course my move look stupid and I have no
hope of having an advantage now because
of my pieces are misplaced but that's
okay so ninety five and once again I
kind of have to figure out what I'm
doing so what do you think's going on
here overall can we find like a plan for
white maybe
sure the night might be strong on d5 and
if black ever plays see 6 then this d6
pawn might be a little bit weak but I
mean if he gets d5 and obviously that
would be totally fine
any other ideas I mean first of all this
pawn is hanging I think so we might have
to deal with that yeah I wasn't really
sure what to do here overall in the long
run right I don't know maybe you guys
are better than me and you can come up
with a plan but I wasn't sure what to do
and that's okay that happens a lot in
chess games right so I just continue
playing simply right I just played b3
defended my pawn and asked him what he
wanted to do he said I want to bring all
my Knights into the game and kill you
and I said please don't do that
but he didn't really listen to me so
okay once again I have no idea what I'm
doing but my opponent has some idea of
what he's doing right he wants to play
something like 93 he wants to play
something like Queen h4 he might want
something like f5 in the future he's
just gonna bring all his pieces in and
try to kill me so once again the only
way to play when you don't know what
you're doing is to try and slow down or
stop your opponent's plan I just started
with Bishop e3 bringing my piece to a
more solid square he went ahead with
Queen h4 I simply played f3 right my
opponent's making threats I'm kind of
just responding and the best most solid
way that I can think of because you know
I can't come up with a plan so f5 he
really wasted no time in a kind of
coming after me like this I simply
played takes on f5 takes an f5 and Queen
check and rook d1 so once again I don't
know if you want to consider the past
few moves part of the early middle game
but all I did was played very simply I
brought my pieces to the center and I
put them on the most solid squares that
I could find and this is always a great
way to kind of fall back if you don't
a real plan is just improving your
pieces bringing them towards the center
and making sure everything's solid which
I don't know if you would call my whole
position solid here but it's a solid as
I could make it
you just plays your d8 taking his time
and let's see
I played Queen d2 here making a threat
and kind of stepping out of any c6 move
you went ahead with 93 so this move is
easy Rick f1f for this move is also easy
my bishops attacked so I came to d4 he
just plays wreck f5 and okay so you
might consider this past the early
middle game now but I didn't have to
make a whole lot of decisions in the
past kind of 10 moves which is kind of
what happens when you're playing against
your opponent's plan is they make a lot
of the decisions for you and you just
have to try to play in the most solid
way you can and play against their plan
so ok now what should I do
finally I get to make a decision my
opponent is going to play rook h5
probably right this is the idea but it's
not checkmate just yet I can play
something like h3 so how do you want to
deal with this threat
this one
yes 2018 Pan Am's
mmm the YouTube chat is losing faith in
my position but in reality if you think
about it right how many mistakes is
white really made this game apologize
been up how many mistakes is white
really made this game so okay I mean you
can consider nighty to night tech C to a
mistake right I played the wrong move
there but after that I've just been
playing natural moves I've been
defending my pieces and I've been
responding my opponents threats so
really why should white be worse here
you know what I mean that's that's not
really how chess works if you don't make
any bad moves you don't lose the game
normally
94 okay I'll play wreckage 5
I guess you have to play h3 now
yeah it might be playable actually I
simply didn't want to make any
weaknesses I wanted to stay solid the
same thinking I've been talking about
the whole time I played king h1 he
played her cage 5 I simply dropped
Bishop back to g1 right
staying solid and eventually you know
this Knight is not gonna stay here
forever that was kind of what I was
banking all my hopes on is someday in
the far off distance I will have to move
he went ahead and played rook f8 and now
I get to do something right so I haven't
really had a plan for the past 10 moves
15 moves really and I've been playing
fine moves though right just responding
to threats and so now I can start to
once again just activate my pieces so
how can I go about that
well maybe playing against my opponent's
pieces
I'm 94 might be fine but I really wanted
to get rid of these Knights right so
yeah well actually no I played 94 I was
wrong I got rid of the Knights later
you're the best Jacob okay
b6 so I brought the other night up to d4
Queen e7 and now I played a3 which is a
bad move right so here is my big plan I
wanted to make this knight move like
this attacking the knight and I didn't
want him to be able to play Knight
before this was literally my only
thinking but of course you know up until
now I've been improving my pieces I've
been responding to threats and then my
opponent makes me make lets me make one
decision and I kind of lose the urgency
of the position so I'm still kind of
being attacked and there's still things
I need to look out for so there is
actually a very good move here for white
which I never would have played in a
million years in the game but I'll be
impressed I'll give you guys five points
if you can find it this is the first
time ever I'm offering up any points on
the road to 2,000 so take your chance
now nope just five five general points
yep
if white finds this move White's killing
it what's the best no I never would have
played it you could have told me I could
have played it and I still wouldn't have
played it
all right you get five points so of
course you know ug4 is not at via not at
the forefront of your mind here but g4
is the freeing move that white needs to
stay in this game and the point is you
cannot take on pissant because I will
take back a rare idea in chess
recapturing a piece and now this this
rook doesn't really have anywhere to go
and that's hard to believe but kind of
kind of true right I guess you can come
to this square but yeah ff4 so you have
this fork if you go here you have this
either one of these Forks I don't know
sure still f4 oh yeah it's just f4 okay
force is the problem right so there you
go I never would have found that but
that's the move and it's pretty close to
winning for white yeah neither would I I
don't think my opponent did either I
don't think anybody on planet earth saw
this well the game was happening so I
simply played a 3 which is just wrong if
anything else I should probably just
play Queen e2 or Queen c2 immediately
rather than kind of waste this time
because my opponent didn't give up
Queeny Queeny 7 looks like he's giving
up on the attack but he definitely
didn't give up on the attack so a 395
kind of a showing the foolishness the
foolishness of my move I captured he
captured
I played Knight to b5 which is fine you
played knight c6 play tricky one
I played a rookie for and now I'm kind
of kind of losing the thread right so I
stopped being able to find out what my
opponents plan was because he got too
tricky for me so if I had realized my
opponents plan I probably would have
played differently so what do you think
black is trying to do here it's a
three-step process and it's hard to stop
as I found out in the game
checkmate
well that's not check man yeah I'll give
you a hint checkmate right so he moved
his queen out of the way
and he's doing this and then he's doing
this and then he's doing this and then
I'm resigning well you know or getting
check made so how can I actually stop
this what should I be playing here
the answer is pretty sad and it shows
why a white is actually in quite a bit
of trouble anyways here
well sacking the exchange is a little
bit worse than that I'm willing to give
up and it turns out probably actually
even on this move I have to play h3
giving my king of flight square so you
know of course this is not this is not
anywhere near ideal and so I probably
would have lost this game of the long
run anyways but the ending was pretty
pretty sad for me you just play his
knight there and then after a while
after this move I guess I realized so
okay I can come back but then just not
here and it's it's over so I could play
h3 but then just Knight here and it's
it's over so I I ended up losing pretty
horribly here and I resigned here but
okay what was the point of that game is
once again when you can't find a plan it
makes a lot of sense to play against
your opponent's plan and start playing
prophylactic moves that prevent his plan
and stay solid play simple moves that
improve your pieces and then you really
can't be worse if you don't play bad
moves you can't be worse no matter how
the position actually looks with that of
Mines I have one more game to show you
this is a game I played against GM
Nicola Mick Cove and this was at I
believe the Midwest class of last year
Midwest class sounds right and so once
again we found ourselves in an opening
where I was unfamiliar unfamiliar with
the opening unfamiliar with what was
happening of course I know the
nimzo-indian which happens after this
and I know the let's see here I know the
rogozin which happens after this but I
was unfamiliar with this line which is
some somewhere in between right
black hasn't actually committed this
Knight to f6 white hasn't committed this
knight to f3 so things are a little bit
weird I decided to clarify it
immediately with a three he captured he
played Knight f6
and plate III and I just developed my
pieces in the opening I played this 95
move which was a bit weird and probably
wrong but that's not what the class is
about today the class is about the early
middle game I simply developed my pieces
and after Bishop d2 rook e8 we kind of
have kind of have the start of the
middle game I think my works are
connected and so once again I'm
unfamiliar with the position
I really haven't played many too many
positions exactly like this with this
kind of structure so let's figure out
what should White be doing how should I
play whoops let me take off the notation
so this one is a bit more clear than the
last two examples it's not impossible to
find a plan for white here right and all
of the cases the answer has been one
responding to a pony's plan and to
improving our own pieces so with that in
mind let's try to find a way to improve
our pieces while keeping in mind our
opponents plan so what is our opponent
trying to do he kind of told us with
this rikiei move what he wants what does
he want to do in the next next couple
moves
any ideas
so there works on e8 right so it's
supporting this pawn so of course it's
supporting this pawn push does that make
sense
so that's blacks idea is he wants to
play e5 and now in a perfect world what
does white want to do right where are
whites weak points how does and he so I
guess in a perfect world white wants to
get rid of his weaknesses and then you
know improves pieces so what are whites
weaknesses that's where we can start
what pawns or squares can black attack
and the way in the white position here
any ideas
Black's already attacking one of them
that's ain't
c3 pawn right does that make sense so
any backward pawn on a half-open file is
gonna be a weakness that a you know can
be targeted so in a perfect world white
would want to get rid of this pawn and
the way he can achieve that is by
playing c4 and doing something like
taking on d5 right so say black does
nothing I get to get rid of my weakness
and now I can use my pieces and black
has nothing to attack of course it's not
a perfect world though so I wanted to
play c4 but on c4 I knew what my
opponent was kind of planning right he
played rook e8 which kind of shows me
that his idea is gonna be to play this
pawn forward he's supporting this pawn
with his rook and now I wasn't sure what
was going on here this looked rather
complicated right because okay maybe I
can take here but maybe he'll take on a
on d4 and all of a sudden this pawns
kind of hanging right there's not much I
can do about it if I tried to defend it
black could actually just capture
because of this pen you know I can't
take back because the Queen would be
hanging so all of a sudden after E 5 I
really didn't know what was going on so
I decided not to play c4 so what else
can white do right I still want to
improve my pieces but I know my
opponent's planned and they need to keep
that in mind and so of course if he
plays a 5 and I haven't played c4 this
threat doesn't really exist right he's
never gonna take on d4 because that does
exactly what I want so as long as this
pawns on c3 c5 is not really gonna be
too big of a problem for me so what that
of Mines what other ideas can I come up
with to improve my pieces maybe open
stuff up for my rooks open up files for
my rooks on the Queen side
you guys heard of the minority attack in
chess no that's totally fine
so a pawn minority is when you have say
something like one pawn or two pawns
against upon majority so in this case
the majority is two pawns and the
minority is this one a pawn so a very
common idea in chess is to use your pawn
minority to break down the pawn majority
right so alone pawns are pretty weak
right they can't the you know the pawns
are at their best when they're with
other pawns where they can be defended
and you know they can kind of block
things down
whereas this pawns alone so it's gonna
be a bit weaker right if it's attacked I
have to use a piece to defend it I can't
use another pawn so I want to kind of
reverse the roles there and I played a
four so of course the idea is I used my
pawn minority to attack the pawn
majority and all of a sudden I've
created a weakness in the black camp
right black is gonna have to now use
pieces to defend this pawn whereas you
know before hands I had the weak pawn so
this is a common idea and so I chose
this plan over the other plan because it
respects my opponent opponents plan as
well this is how you can kind of come up
with moves is figuring out what your
opponent wants to do figuring out what
you want to do and then making your best
decision based on all these plans so
with that in mind black didn't play King
h8 I think I got off of the game
continuation here somewhere so I'm sorry
I actually played rook c1 first
my opponent played a five and then I
played a four with the same idea I
simply brought my rook to the C file
first my opponent didn't want to sit
back and just kind of let this happen so
he went ahead and played e4 attacking my
bishop
I played Bishop b5 because coming back
to this to either one of these squares
actually has a pretty significant
problem
and I'll let you guys try and find what
what the problem would be with something
like this it involves whites weakness
and black would be able to kind of fix
this weakness on c3 make it so I can't
ever play the c-4 move that I wanted to
do
what do you think some way to control
this square how can we attack that
square
any idea yeah with the bishop right we
can simply play play Bishop basics
controlling the c-4 square gaining a
tempo on the Queen actually the Queen
might go somewhere off alone on the
Kings side or it might you know stay
closer to home but either way this pawn
is going to be pretty permanently stuck
here and that's bad because it's one a
weakness and number two this Bishop is
gonna kind of be stuck looking at it so
definitely can't allow that
which is why in the game I played Bishop
b5 so this of course falls into this
forcing line after a6 attacking my
bishop they can't go back
it can't go forward so it has to trade
itself off for this night and after
Queen takes fortunately I can play c4
immediately now before Black has the
chance to kind of fix it as a weakness
so in the game you played Bishop c6 I
played a5 he took I took and we got to
this position so what do you think's
going on here who would you rather be
white or black or do you think it's
equal
let me hear your thoughts you'd rather
be black so why is that yes so you've
got this past pawn so that is that is
kind of an advantage for black it can
also be a weakness sometimes right
because it is isolated so if the pawn
were on a 4 I would definitely agree
with you cuz the further advanced a
passed pawn gets the more powerful it is
because it's closer to becoming a queen
at the end of the board
but with this pawn kind of stuck on a6
it's probably not going to be too
dangerous right and the main feature of
the position that I think would change
my evaluation of it is the fact that
he's the LightSquared Bishop and I have
a dark squared Bishop right so are you
guys familiar with opposite colored
Bishop endgames yes so usually they're
drawn and the reason for that is they
kind of are playing different games
right this bishops playing a game on the
dark square dark square complex and the
suspicious playing on the light squares
I can never really interact with each
other so what this means is you know
both sides can very often form blockades
what are blockades they're ways to kind
of stop pawns from advancing right so no
matter what black does he's gonna have a
tough time forcing my bishop off of this
square so that he can advance this pawn
because this bishop simply can't attack
this bishop ever so in the end I was
pretty confident that this was totally
dead drawn neither side really has many
chances here and that's because of these
opposite colored bishops the fact that
white doesn't have any weaknesses and
the fact that white really can't make a
meaningful attack against this a pawn so
with that in mind I want to go back
actually a few moves so with this in
mind after a 4 I can't I kind of
calculated this all out right it's a
very forcing line after E 4 I have to
play Bishop b5 after a6 I have to take
on d7 and after c4 I was pretty
confident I knew what we were heading
towards here
so if I were playing a weaker player
then a GM I might have tried to be a
little bit more ambitious so now that we
know that blacks plan is going to be to
play e4 what can we do to try to stop
this plan to keep the game going
we want to stop Evora somehow from
closing off our bishop
how can we control this glare it's not
really a trick question simply defend
efore so that black won't push
see if someone in YouTube has suggested
it simply f3 you just defend against the
threat and so this is the type of
thinking that you should really be
following in your games you want to play
your plan but if you can really put a
stop in your opponent's plan it's
usually worthwhile to do it and I think
white is actually doing pretty well
after f3 one of the main reasons for
that is he has you know slightly a
slightly bigger Center slightly more
central control Black has two Center
pawns you know on e5 and d5 but they are
a bit loose and the main thing is you
know White has the bishop pair and the
bishops work well together
someone else in YouTube suggested efore
which is a bit too crazy I think after
pawn takes d4 there's this annoying pin
but so okay I think looking back I
probably should have played f3 if I
wanted to try to win this game but you
know I was some punk 2100 playing a
grandmaster I didn't want to play on I
wanted to draw so I played a4 and went
in for this line and we arrived at this
end game which really by all rights
neither side should really have anything
to play for and we probably should have
agreed to a draw here but my opponent
was some 400 points higher rated than me
and wanted to win and he very nearly did
so I guess we can take a look at it
he played rock c8 I brought my queen off
of the same file as the rook because
that's scary and I don't like being
scared
I played Bishop d5 I simply moved my
queen we traded one set of rooks and you
can kind of see both sides aren't doing
a great deal I actually start repeating
moves here and he starts walking his
King up the board which was a little
strange to me but not much progress
being made
so you can kind of see how this a v
square is something black can never
really control thanks to my bishop and
so if he wants to make any progress he
really does need to control this a v
square so that's why nothing much is
happening in the long run though
something did happen we turned it off
another set of rooks and I played this
Bishop d6 move which is honestly just
just a little bit silly and the reason
for that is now you can play a five so
of course if I take this Bishop is
actually hanging now I needed the Queen
to defend it so I have to do something
else so I play Queen c5
he plays Bishop b3 I play King g3
actually Queen f5 and I decided to go in
for f4 which is a little crazy I could
have just taken here but I was a little
worried about the son game actually I
thought maybe the black King being so
close to the pawn would help black one
which is why I chose the slightly
strange looking at floor first so now
the idea is his King is still closer to
the Queen side but I can make my own
past pawn which will give him some
problems with getting over to the Queen
side so some more moves happened and
this onion would be totally over if not
for how far advanced this pawn is if
this phone was still in a6 there would
really be nothing to play for here
so eventually black does try something
with f5 but it's simply not enough
simply not enough you did eventually
give up here and we agreed to a draw the
important thing is to notice that you
can't really take this because I will
take all of his pawns and eventually
sacrifice my Bishop for his last pot and
the game will be a draw so those were
the three games I had for today any
questions about this one there's a
little bit more straightforward than the
first to anything you didn't understand
at all alright so just to recap the big
ideas I wanted to show today are in the
early middle game if you don't know what
to do it's important to stop and if you
can't figure out what you're supposed to
do think about what your opponent wants
to do and if you figure that out then
you can kind of play moves that makes
sense trying to stop your opponent's
plan that's the way to kind of think
about it and if you can't find a plan
for anybody the thing to fall back on is
always improve your pieces find ways to
make your pieces better for example here
my rooks
aren't doing much and my bishop isn't
doing much so I want to improve my
pieces I want to play moves like c4 I
want to play moves like a4 a5 and open
some files so yeah those are the big
things improve your pieces stop your
opponent's plan any questions overall
alright well I think I'm gonna call the
class here then thank you guys for
coming out hopefully I'll learn
something today and I'll see you next
week on the road to 2000s
you